attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
et enfin le salon je vous préviens ça
fait six mois que c'est ta part donc si
je peux vous le refourguer ça
m'arrangerait ah ben ça m'arrange aussi
parce que je me prends refus sur un flux
d un dossier de merde qu'en fait c'est
ma copine qui m'a quitté elle m'a trompé
et du coup celle qui a gardé
l'appartement chez un peu président
c'est intéressant je vais oublier un
psychologue
et c'est quoi ce copier pendéliau
l'asthme des strip teaseuses
l'ancien locataire était branché q le
propriétaire ou laisse une table et une
chaise pourrait donc c'est un meublé
si vous permet d'augmenter le loyer 30%
à 1 vous connaissez la carotte et ckoi
l'exposition de l'appartement
ici c'est plein sud mais là c'est les
murs je veux dire du côté de la fenêtre
belle à ses pianos ou n'auraient pas de
soleil et d'un très bon quel est le gros
atout de cet appartement a déjà c'est
pas le papier peint j'ai pas la hauteur
sous plafond non la voisine d'en face
vingt deux ans étudiant naturiste par
contre la voisine du dessous c'est une
vieille elle s'emmerde vous allez voir
vous faire chier toute la journée et 88
ans courait pas ce rappel et gazier les
commet
oui un peu pourri mais bon je vous
laisse mon dossier quand même dedans il
ya un milliard en moins dernier avis
d'imposition et mes trois dernières
fiches de paie c'est votre salaire ça ah
non non c'est celui qui sévit pour avoir
l'appartement mais comme tout le monde
j'ai eu peur vous savez quoi
si on vous le montre ces documents c'est
seulement qu'on me faire chier un nous
en vrai on choisit à la tête du client
et j'aurai la réponse quand ou là et
beaucoup aussi à étudier vous n'êtes pas
seuls c'est minimum deux semaines on a
dû me dit dans l'ope et et amour
bienvenue
[Musique]